To defeat mistakes, we must pick up mistakes.
We must defend all fronts to ensure
They were arrested early and often.
Checking during loading helps, but there are also
A full set of runtime checks can also be used.
This is where StrictMode comes in,
Provide a set of run-time checks for you
You can add to your debug structures to capture potential problems
Before they reach users.
I am Ian Lake, I will introduce you two
Of the best properties for StrictMode
Which exceed performance verification
And help you to build better applications
If problems with links are problems that appear at load time
In StrictMode
Is equivalent to run-time, causing problems
We can detect them at runtime so you can fix them early.
Most StrictMode focuses on performance.
Ian the other works great work is modern
About these properties in their video
As well as the basics of StrictMode
But I'm not here to rework it.
Instead, let's talk about new things,
Such as the VM policy .detectFileUriExposure
If you share content with other apps,
You do not want to use the URL of the file.
They need permission to store
And can not move between users
And - well, just watch the Dave Byte video on the content sharing.
StrictMode makes sure only that
URLs do not go to other applications.
Like any StrictMode, you can
Register this problem using PenaltyLog or close your application completely
With PenaltyDeath.
Build applications or die
It's a simple choice, is not it?
Now, the new Android 6.0 Marshmallow
Is detectCleartextNetwork.
As you can expect from the name,
This detects the movement of unencrypted network data over IPv4 or IPv6,
Whether you are using TCP or UDP
The thing about mobile devices is in the wild
Is that you can not guarantee
They will be connected
With reliable access points.
Risking the security of your user data
Or contacts to your server
Another nightmare is the privacy you want
Deal with the launch day.
So check it out early and encrypt your network data.
One thing, you have to keep in mind, you may find false alarms
When using STARTTLS protocols or HTTP proxies.
It should be noted that StrictMode will close it
Although they are correct
Now, with your application created additional logs
And closed it all, maybe
You take into account that StrictMode
It should only be run in beta versions.
The easiest way to do this is by placing StrictMode calls
In the buildConfig check, it is automatically generated
Avoids non-experimental versions
There's a lot to discover in StrictMode
But detect URLs and network data traffic
Can be very useful in finding problems
Before users suffer,
Giving you peace of mind
And manufacturing better applications
[Music]